quelque chose d'un peu avait dépêché oui
on cherche on cherche sur tout qu'est-ce
qu'on va les mettre dans les sacs
poubelle elle a tout essayé
dépêchez-vous pour un retour de la dame
lui écoute il faut quelque chose pour ce
soir apple et voilà madame nous avons
trouvé voilà notre dernière création où
passait pas malgré cette origine le
passé tout de suite
voilà vous mettez un petit oui bah oui
ça va aller ça allait bien il ya joué
remplacer mais évidemment si ça déborde
et vous ne pourrez plus faire oui oui et
oui ça va pas traîner
bah écoutez je suis emmerdé c'est normal
oui parce que je grossis en ce moment on
s'en fout complètement
est ce qu'il y à d'autres tailles par la
suite écoutez aucun problème on a tout
l'état on va jusqu'au sang jusqu'au sang
oui évidemment jusqu'au sens libre
d'envoyer marie-pierre on essaie la
petite c'est rognon vous allez vous
chercher des trucs par là vous savez
avec nicole nous avons voulu faire déjà
méfaits du jamais vu non c'est pourquoi
nous appelons ce petit ensemble sacs
poubelles
oui écoutez passé de mon concert je
jouais bien vu dans une autre table ah
oui et bien non et bien non madame hull
oui ça me désole mais ça n'existe
pendriez plus ses standards oui et à
partir de grand d'auteuil nous ne
voulons plus que dans le vrai
ces pages à écouter avec chaleur avec
les boks transpire amelio adam un non
madame mais dont vous ce n'est pas de la
transpiration un joli nom sac pour vous
fait émettre une très fine vapeur d'eau
qui dilate les pores de la peau pour la
débarrasser de ses moindres impuretés
chère madame vous voyez que ça doit
vraiment rien à voir avec de la tension
parmi eux joué du tout dites moi qu'est
ce que je vais mettre comme chaussures
avec un [ __ ] mais alors fin au petit
mon père c'est vrai nous avons les boots
qui colle avec l'ensemble des
collections et maintenant je veux bien
je ne vois pas comment on va écouter non
c'est bon on a tous là également les
pies noires bien les draps les doubles
rideaux ou la wii lula et puis les
parfois aussi j'ai pas fait ça pour
russell a par la suite
l'intéressé dans les églises où ils
espèrent elles ont marché un petit peu
pour la gravure est si vous permettez ça
vous donne une main du plastique mais là
les problèmes mais bon à droite oui je
le perds un peu le talon a passerait
bien l'article de mions ou voiliers au
nom vous savez si vous mettez une
petites socquettes par exemple savoir la
bonne paye trop chaussettes labonal ou
bien s'en suivent les fenêtres et la
sacra rien tôt mark hix attendant on
s'est totalement étanche on va mais
madame le pied court le pied dedans oui
ça va je sais jouir la neige et famille
sous la pluie la qualité de sa poupe se
voir écouter madame j'irai même plus
loin la qualité de sacs poubelles villes
espagnoles
moi je dirais même plus et il seconde
pour vers la ville avait hérité j'ai un
vernissage ce soir un jeu le mène
directement mais ça il y aura beaucoup
de monde mon mari m'a approché pour
écouter madame s'il ya du monde et en
plus la chaleur je vais vous dire que
votre mari il faudra plus que d'approché
et on va même à des rivaux sahraoui
entre vous ce soir ça va très fort
collet ne vous poser une question à
poser
je me pose aucun problème du tout mais
combien
pado oui le prix de ce ravissant orthez
à louis marie pierre vos amis
oui oui alors le bustier vous fera mille
la jupe 2000 oui et les boues se mettre
1000 la fondation mozilla du doubs pour
un petit ensemble qu'eva marmonnier
américaine
oui complète mois au mieux c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qu'il est amené un petit
aguichant parisien petit b brillant
parisien petit sol et craquant par inès
bien sûr petit délire en eau par ici
avec damas j'ai rien parier que tu t'es
fait ligne parisien ça je dise les
jarrets l'a fait petit et tant mieux
mais coûte chère madame surtout qu'aucun
louis vous avez tout de suite par le
côté pratique de cette pompe à eau par
exemple vous voulez ramener quelques
toasts vous les mettez dans cette poule
voilà et puis en arrivant chez vous vous
mettez le tout offre et sacs ou
directement au frigo ça fait super mois
passé contre les droits polyvalent comme
la tablette est mort le lendemain à
votre de du reste fraîche on va juste un
petit coup d'épaulé à pékin j'entends
bien je peux reste andré une éponge
grattoir pour la prochaine fois ça sera
bien pour moi je crois que cette poupe
ça va être tendu avec madame sa coupe
c'est la puissance industrielle au
service de pouce elle oui merci
à écouter oui je vais le prendre et puis
je me dépêchais j'ai parfois mortelles
sisters au moins vous inquiétez foyer la
benne qui passe à 6 heures
je suis emballé un ah oui ça valait 1
marie vieille madame
ils s'attendent à les encorbellements
d'engagement en valais je le prends en
carrière je me gardais son regard aimant
je suis plein du jour écoutez madame si
vous êtes plein on va vous descendre